[MUSIC PLAYING]
ARIE MEIR: My name is Arie.
I'm a product manager
on Google Cloud,
in the cloud health
care organization,
and the title of this panel
is Telemedicine, A Global
Perspective.
So I'm very honored
and fortunate to host
four of our partners,
representatives
from four different
organizations.
And they would like to
share with you some aspects
of the work, of what
our partners are doing
and what some of the
commonalities, some
of the interesting
idiosyncrasies of what they're
seeing in their respective
fields and geographies.
We'd love to
[? extend ?] [INAUDIBLE]
that makes sense to share
a little bit of how Google
is approaching the space
and how our cloud platform
and technology helps play
a role in this context.
So maybe we can start by
each one of our participants
introduce themselves,
and kind of the mission
and the organization
that they represent.
LORENZO RIZZATTO: Good
morning, everyone.
My name is Lorenzo Rizzatto.
I come from Italy.
I serve as a technical
director for two companies.
One is a telemedicine,
teleradiology company
active in Italy, and
the second one is--
we provide cloud services for
archiving and distribution
of medical images.
And the name of the
company is O3 Enterprise.
Yep.
TAKASHI TOCHI: Hi, my name
is Takashi Tochi from MNES.
We established this company
in 2000 in Hiroshima, Japan.
We have two strong points.
One is network of doctors.
More than 70 doctors are
enrolled and work together.
And another is system, our
system, our original system
for image diagnosis.
We developed that on
the base of cloud, GCP.
And leveraging those
two strong points,
we are trying to expand the
possibility, the availability
of the teleradiology, as
the title of this session.
We are very confident that
teleradiology can bring
lots of merits to our society.
Our society doesn't
know that yet.
We want to bring out
its full potential.
DANIEL MOLLURA: Hi, everyone.
I'm Dan Mollura.
I'm the CEO of
Rad-Aid International.
So we're a nonprofit
organization
that brings radiology
to low resource regions,
developing countries.
We were founded in 2008 to
address the problem that
radiology is missing
in about half
to two thirds of the world.
That means that all
the medical images that
are so vital for diagnosing
and treating disease
are mostly absent in these low
and middle-income countries.
We have about 11,000 volunteers
that go to these countries
to build radiology capacities.
So that might mean donating
equipment, doing trainings,
education for health personnel
to use medical imaging in a way
that can benefit the patients.
A large part of what
we do now is also
donating the IT
infrastructure and bringing
in PACS and other IT
infrastructures that
are vital for bringing the
images from the scanners
over to the workstations so
that they can be interpreted,
which, of course, raises
the big opportunity
for long-term artificial
intelligence development
and other advanced
IT infrastructures.
So it's great work
that we love doing
and it's great to be here.
Thanks.
RAFAEL DE CASTRO
FIGUEROA: Hello everyone.
I'm Rafael, co-founder
and CEO of Portal.
We are a telediagnostic
platform that connects clinics,
hospitals, and governments.
Our goal is to provide access
to quality health care,
especially in remote areas.
So we develop a
technology that integrates
with medical devices.
So the nurse, usually, or a
general physician, do the exam,
data is automatically
transferred to the cloud,
and the medical specialists like
a neurologist or cardiologist
makes the diagnostic online.
This result is available
in the same day
to our network of
clients of 500 hospitals
and 300 cities in
Brazil and Africa.
Through our proprietary data set
of about 30 million patients,
we train machine learning
models running in TensorFlow
to automatically detect
diseases in these exams.
So whenever the ML
model detects a disease,
it assigns a risk
score and moves it up
in the queue to emergencies.
So this is how we do such a
large scale because we use ML
to prioritize their emergence.
So the doctors do the
diagnostics on top of this.
Our goal here at Next,
we're looking for partners
to help in this global
expansion and in our mission
to provide universal
access to health care.
Thank you.
ARIE MEIR: Thank you, folks.
So this has been, actually,
a personal dream of mine
to bring people from solving
a very similar challenge
in different
geographies, and kind
of trying to find what's common
and what's idiosyncratic.
In my mind I was calling it
the Medical Imaging Olympics.
We have a representative from
four different geographies.
So it sounds like
the problem we're all
trying to approach,
your organizations,
is increasing access
to quality care.
So you have expertise
in one place
and you have the people
who need to benefit from it
in a different place.
What do you find idiosyncratic?
What's kind of unique
from your observation
and your conversations
with colleagues
from other parts of
the world that might
be unique to your geography?
We don't have necessarily
to go by order.
Whoever feels like they
have something, jump in.
RAFAEL DE CASTRO FIGUEROA: OK.
So what I see in
similarities and difference,
first, is the matter
of legislation.
I believe each of us has a
different scenario to operate.
And especially, Dan, when
people say Africa is not Africa.
There are a lot of
different countries
with different regulation.
We think in the case of the
US, there's different states.
So, for example, in Brazil, we
have one legislation's federal,
and with this
legislation, we can
do diagnostics between the
states with no problem.
Here in the US, there
are several states
that doesn't allow the
license for the other states,
so you need to hire
local doctors, which
is one of the barriers of the
adoption of telediagnostics
here.
And also in terms
of technology, I'm
surprised to see that what I
thought was a problem in Brazil
in emerging markets, for
example, interoperability,
that the systems don't
talk between them,
and the devices also
have a lot of problems
with proprietary files, we're
seeing similar issues happen
in the US and Europe as well
for different reasons, maybe.
Like very big vendors that
don't want to integrate,
as opposed in
Brazil, we have a lot
of smaller vendors, which
do want to integrate.
So I see as a matter
of technical challenge,
most emerging markets
as there are here,
and some places in Europe as
more of a political challenge
between these big players.
But it's nice to see that we
have a lot of similarities
between the way that we work.
And this is one of
the reasons that we
are using GCP, because
there's some infrastructure
challenges that is
similar between us,
and Google is helping
us to solve them.
DANIEL MOLLURA: Yeah,
so Rafael's right.
There's a lot of
heterogeneity, diversity
across these locations.
Rad-Aid works in 30 countries
and about 55 hospitals.
So we see a lot of differences
across these locations.
I think the big thing
that we're finding
that's idiosyncratic and
important to point out
is that with all this technology
development and the algorithms
and what's coming for the future
of artificial intelligence
in health care and
medicine, Rad-Aid
is here to empower the user.
There is still a gap between the
user, which is the health care
professional, and the great
technologies that are capable.
So by empowering the
user, we're talking
about really retraining
health care workers
to think a little differently
in their clinical practice
and how they adopt technologies
into their daily work.
And that's something we can
do by integrating things
like cloud and AI into the
practice of health care.
And we're finding
that that's going
to require a lot of on-site
work and a lot of understanding
of what the uniqueness
characteristics are
of these hospitals and how
they work in their cultures
and appreciating what that
heterogeneity might be,
but at the same time leveraging
the great technologies that
are coming from this
kind of context.
TAKASHI TOCHI: Talking
about a common feature
of teleradiology,
especially, this
is very similar
with Dan's Rad-Aid.
Please let me explain
about our Mongol project.
Now we're proceeding
a three-year project
with Mongol doctors.
Every year we hold a
one-week training seminar
in our office in
Hiroshima, Japan,
inviting Mongolian doctors.
In that seminar, firstly, we
teach them how to [INAUDIBLE]
interpret, because Mongolian
doctors are still a little bit
behind in their
diagnostic skills.
So we teach them how to
read, how to interpret,
but rather, we focus on teaching
them how to use our system.
That's because that's a kind
of preparation for elearning.
Of course, one-week
training seminar,
that's not enough to
build strong skills.
So after the seminar is over,
they're back to their hometown,
and while they're making
diagnosis in their daily job,
they consult with
us via our system.
Oh, doc, I think this
tumor is not malignant,
do you agree or disagree?
That kind of thing.
One doctor told me, oh,
this is a ideal platform
for consultation.
We can discuss seeing the
same images at one time.
And we can do that with
doctors all over the world.
And not only us, but we all can
do that because that's cloud.
That's cloud's value.
Teleradiology and
cloud are inseparable.
Thank you.
LORENZO RIZZATTO: I believe
that one of the main problems
is standardization,
as Rafael mentioned.
And we face really
big complexities
with collection of data
around the territory,
but as soon as they reach
the cloud, it's all done.
And we have no complex
scenario to face.
And of course, we also
face regulation problems.
As you know, in Europe, we have
since 2018, a new General Data
Protection Regulation,
which is really strict.
And we have to collect
consent from the patients,
and all the process
must be audited
and must be transparent.
So this is made, of course,
easy with Google Cloud,
since the platform
itself is GDPR-compliant.
ARIE MEIR: Thank you, folks.
So one thing I want to point
out that kind of stood out to me
is one of the
idiosyncrasies I remember
when first learning
about [INAUDIBLE] work
is a data point.
And in the US and in Japan,
you have a comparable number
of medical imaging
devices, like CTs and MRIs.
Very similar, maybe
10%, 15% difference.
But the number of doctors,
radiologists in Japan
is, I think, seven times less.
So it creates a huge
scarcity for radiologists.
So it's an interesting
kind of dynamic
that makes you realize that, OK,
this research is very valuable.
I need to optimize
it effectively.
One thing I want to
ask you, if I ask you,
how many people have spoken
to a doctor on the phone here?
The majority of people have.
So in some sense, that's kind
of a basic telemedicine, right?
You're talking to
a doctor remotely.
So the phones have been since
Alexander Bell and the internet
has been around since the '80s.
So what has cloud changed?
Or is it just faster internet?
How are you thinking
about that piece?
LORENZO RIZZATTO:
Well, I believe
that with cloud, the time,
the speed of the process
is much higher, of course.
I am in the sector since 20
years, so I saw all the phases.
For example, for our
teleradiology projects,
we used to have
our own data center
and we used to move,
point to point, all
the [INAUDIBLE] images, so
the biggest projects we had,
they were mammography screening
teleradiology projects.
So it was really a big,
big pain to move the images
from the server to
the single point,
to a single workstation of the
radiologist that was reporting
for [INAUDIBLE], for example.
So it was really a long
process, and many people
were involved to monitor
all the workflow.
But now, with the cloud,
it takes some minutes.
So we collect the images,
we collect the priors
so the actual study
plus the priors,
and then they are immediately
available to everyone
on whatever device
they want to use.
Of course they are using
multi-monitor workstations.
So it takes minutes from
acquisition to reporting.
So this is, in my opinion, one
of the best, the most important
point.
And of course there
are less mistakes
in the process because it's
simplified by technology.
TAKASHI TOCHI: As
Arie told, in Japan,
the ratio of
radiologists to scanners,
that ratio is
ridiculously low in Japan
comparing with other countries.
We have many, many scanners,
CT or MRI scanners,
but the number of radiologists
is strictly limited.
And last year in Japan,
overlooked cancers
became a social problem.
Very famous, large,
respected hospitals,
announced one after another
that they did overlook.
And sadly, some resulted
in patients' deaths.
That gained
nationwide attention.
And as a result,
as you can tell,
the result is raised
expectations for teleradiology.
The radiologists
are short in number.
So in order to centralize
and make it more efficient,
teleradiology is
essential, indispensable.
And in that point, cloud and
teleradiology is inseparable.
And the cloud is essential.
Thank you.
DANIEL MOLLURA: Cloud
brings down costs
and lowers complexity.
It's the basic two
deliverables that a cloud
can bring into a
low-resource environment.
So for example, this past year,
Rad-Aid with Google Cloud,
as well as Ambra and a
logistics company, Tribalco,
implemented a solution
where there was Lao Friends
Hospital for Children.
This was a low-resource
hospital in Laos.
Had no radiology department
at all, practically,
three or four years ago
when we started there.
Now for them to have
PACS, right, this
is the architecture for sending
the images from the scanners
to the workstations.
For them to have done that
using a conventional solution,
Rad-Aid has done that.
We've sent these large racks,
these large servers to places
that had to build a
climate-controlled server room
and do their own storage.
But that was very
complex and very costly.
Imagine a low-resource
hospital having
to build all that
infrastructure and then
have all that IT personnel
within the hospital
to manage it.
It's a very difficult
scenario to manage.
So instead, so the pilot we
did with Google Cloud in Laos,
for example, we came down
with a compact server
that we can hand carry
that's temperature-resistant
so it didn't need any
climate control at all
and had all the preloaded Ambra
PACS software onboard already.
Went to the hospital
and turned it on,
connected it to the
imaging modalities
so that it would
have onsite storage,
but as well it would
immediately backup
to the cloud, which was
the Google Cloud, which
we're calling Rad-Aid Friendship
Cloud in this instance.
So it overcame all of these
logistical barriers that
could have occurred otherwise.
And then it also dramatically
lowered the cost.
So what cloud introduces
is it lowers the barrier
to entry for
low-resource hospitals
to implement their IT
infrastructure by having
a way to really turnkey
transfer images from scanners
to workstations and then have
a way to back up those images.
RAFAEL DE CASTRO
FIGUEROA: I'm going
to share one technical
example that we have.
For machine learning, we used
TensorFlow for the last two
years, since the first versions.
And back then we had, I
think, about 10 models,
because these models
are very narrow.
So it's one model
for a chest X-ray.
We're not going to work in AKGs,
we're not going to work in TCs.
They're very specific.
And every time I tried to
train one of those models
in our own VMs, for example,
we took about five weeks
for each of these models to get
train in [INAUDIBLE] examples.
So just imagine the R&D
cycle for the developers who
have to wait five weeks, see
if the model is better or not
than the last version.
So we've been through
a program that Google
has called Launchpad Studio--
it's an acceleration
program for tech companies--
last year.
And our goal was to apply
the continuous integration
[? parroting ?] in
machine learning.
So the thought of continuous
delivering new models.
And the way that we did that,
we port all the models that we
have for a Cloud ML Engine,
which is managed TensorFlow,
that you can just choose
the metric and the data
set and it trains it for you.
So what used to take five weeks
right now is taking two days.
So how it works now,
we get data sets,
for example, for chest X-ray,
is one of the simplest one.
We have a list of findings--
nodules, TB, pneumonia,
[? consolidation. ?]
And each of those models,
instead of just one
being trained in a
VM for five weeks,
we can put to 100
different containers
to be trained at same time,
and each of those containers
have different neural network
architectures, different layer
sizes, and different
pre-processing techniques
on this.
And because it's pretty much
a trial and error still, deep
learning, you don't
know exactly what
will impact if you change
layers, for example.
So what we do is put
these 100 containers
to be trained at the same
time with just one script
to call this API--
each of these containers will
have a different configuration
of the neural net, for example.
And then after one to two
days, the 100 are trained
and we collect the metrics.
But instead of collecting
the regular metrics
of memory, latency,
[INAUDIBLE] for example,
we collect those as well.
But we also collect the metrics
from the confusion matrix
in TensorFlow.
So accuracy and recall, these
are collected automatically.
And the model that has the best
performance go to production,
the other 99 are killed,
and this is started again.
So each 48 hours we retrain
our whole models again
with the new data that is
coming from these 500 hospitals.
And right now this is
happening without us
having to press any buttons.
It's happening-- actually,
we're doing this weekly.
So every Saturday night
we train with the new data
from the week, but with these
variations of architectures
and layers and stuff like this.
So right now-- and
since we've got this
about eight months
ago, right now
we have 200 different
models running in production
classifying these diseases.
So this is one example of
how it became scalable,
and now our ML engineers can
focus on the models itself
and not in the plumbing around.
And when you stop to see
machine learning work,
I would say that about 90%
of the work is the plumbing.
It's the authentication.
It's data engineering,
organizing, ingesting
this data.
And 10% is actually PhD
machine learning work.
And if you give these PhDs
to do the other parts,
do the DevOps part, they
would take like three,
four times what a good
cloud developer would take.
So it's a way to speed up the ML
work, which is actually usually
high paying per hour people that
don't know how to do the cloud
infrastructure, but they're
very good at math, mathematics.
So to keep them focused
on what they're good at
and the cloud take care
of the plumbing around.
ARIE MEIR: So I guess when
you bring up a AI and medicine
or radiology, the
natural questions
is what is the role
that AI will play
in changing the dynamics
between a doctor and a patient?
And there is the elephant in
the room, kind of question,
will AI replace doctors,
maybe, in certain specialties?
How do you use AI
in your organization
and what's your take on these
changing roles of a doctor,
and will AI replace
or augment doctors?
LORENZO RIZZATTO: Well, in
our opinion, in my opinion, AI
augments doctors.
And so far in our organization
we implemented some models
for prioritizing, as
you mentioned before,
and also to, let's
say, to segment
the studies in order
to assign the studies
to the right doctor.
So, I don't know, for
example, mammography.
Dense breast, so more
difficult, of course, to report.
So what the model does is
a classification of breast
density, and then if the
study is a dense breast,
it goes to an
expert radiologist.
And so this lowers the
risk for the patient.
In my opinion, in the future
it will be more and more.
So why not, maybe,
radiologist will be replaced,
maybe for routine
works, routine reporting
and we'll have more time to
concentrate on, let's say,
most difficult cases.
I believe so.
TAKASHI TOCHI:
Talking about AI, I
want to share the
ironical situation
in Japan, ironical situation
of approval in Japan.
Through the collaboration
with start up AI vendors,
we have developed several
AIs, and our doctors,
and all the doctors
have used them
since more than two years ago.
So now they know a lot about
AI, good and bad, its usefulness
and its limits both.
But maybe we Japanese are
very conservative people.
And our national health ministry
has approved just one AI
by now.
Many vendors have
developed many AIs.
But still just one approval.
And on the media
or among doctors,
the pros and cons of AI still
remains as a matter of dispute,
but from the viewpoint of our
doctors, the doctors with lots
of experience of AI,
from their point of view
that dispute seems to be
irrational, one-dimensional.
For example, some
doctors expect too much.
Oh, AI's going to do many,
many things with 100% accuracy.
No, no, no.
Or some others fear too much.
Oh, AI's going to drive
us out of business.
No.
My take is, just give
them the opportunity
of hands-on AI trial
as soon as possible.
After a couple of weeks of
using AI, maybe they know,
they will realize that
reality, good and bad.
And that dispute would be more
realistic, more down to earth.
And I think that would be
beneficial for our health
ministry too.
DANIEL MOLLURA: This
is a great question.
I'm a radiologist, so I'm
right in the middle of this.
Is AI going to replace
me, for example?
Most of us believe
at this point that AI
is going to increase quality
and increase efficiency,
but it can't really replace
the human caregiver.
Human patients really
need a human caregiver.
It's the human condition.
So no one's trying to advocate
that machines should take over
this particular role.
But it can improve
the speed at which
we do things and the quality
at which we do things.
So a couple of
examples have been
suggested, like a
basic triage role,
for triaging the
different cases--
ones that are
abnormal from normal
or ones that deserve immediate
attention versus ones
that can wait--
acute disease or
emergency versus something
that's chronic and can be dealt
with at a different velocity
in the care context.
So these are different
scenarios that AI can deliver.
But what's very true, and
what was just mentioned,
is that AI is really
not in our context yet.
When I go to work
on a daily basis
there is no AI that I'm
aware of in my midst.
But it is in the future.
So we're trying
to incorporate it
into the vision of what
the profession will have.
But what's also
important, though,
is that once you
start integrating AI
into the clinical
care workflow, you're
really changing
the way that doctor
is going to do their job.
And that means
retraining that person
for how their job
is now influenced
by this new capability.
So it doesn't
transfer very easily.
It doesn't just
happen overnight,
because that doctor is still
responsible for the life
of the patient.
So they're not just
going to hand it over.
So like you just heard, only
one approval of an AI mechanism
so far.
I mean, that's not
surprising because we're
talking about the fact that the
human care on the other side
is still at risk if
that AI doesn't work.
So that transfer needs
to happen in a way that's
careful and trained.
So I think what
comes from this is
a great interest in education
for health providers
to really think
about how they would
use AI in those workflows.
RAFAEL DE CASTRO
FIGUEROA: I'm going
to open with a fun
quote, that, what is AI?
Because I heard, like, if it's
reading in Python and C++,
it's probably machine learning.
If it's reading in
PowerPoint, it's probably AI.
And so we need to differentiate
things and in our case,
was a matter of
adoption for the doctors
because we started to
trust these models with how
we approach doctors who use it.
And in our case, in
health care specifically,
cannot be an end in itself.
It need to be a
mean to something.
And once we started to do
a lot of data diagnostics
we started to hit the
first bottleneck, which
was prioritization.
So even if we give the
results in same day,
24 hours can be too much,
depending on the case.
So we approached doctors
in a very light way.
What do you think if you
prioritized emergencies?
And then we ran about six
months of a dual pipeline
of the predictions
against a regular nurse
prioritizing things for them.
We have a nurse full time
to take care of this.
And It was obvious
that the prioritization
made by ML models was
being better and faster--
milliseconds.
And so they agreed.
And then after one
year using this,
when do we hit about 90%
recall, which is very low false
negatives-- we train everything
for recall first, specificity--
we say, OK, now we trust
enough in these models
to do a double check.
So if the algorithm predicts,
for example, pneumothorax,
that could be fatal
if not treated fast--
you move it up in
the queue in seconds
to get to the radiology.
But if it clicks
normal, he didn't
see it because you can have
very small pneumothorax,
then the system sends
to three other doctors
and create a board of
consensus between them.
Of course, it's a blind
test for all of them.
They think they're
first opinion.
But then with this,
we could rule out
these kind of mistakes.
And then a data point--
it's not me saying this.
It's a study by Harvard,
which is the doctor
precision is around 80%.
Depend of the modality,
of course, but when
you stop and think about
it, of 100 stage one
cancer with a very small nodule,
80 will be found and 20 not.
Probably going to be diagnosed
late with a stage two or three.
So now when you
approach a doctor,
OK, if you made a
mistake, the system
will send to three other doctor,
so this kind of small things
are not going to be
a liability for you.
And then they said
OK, let's try it.
Same thing.
We did a dual pipeline and they
started to trust the models.
And now we are using this--
of those 200 models that
we have, with all of them
for prioritization,
and we have 40
that we trust enough
to do the double check.
And so it's a matter
of how you approach it.
And last example is that what
is the KPIs that the doctors are
looking for?
Is different KPIs for us as the
company managing this platform,
but for them, most
of the time it's
how many diagnostics I can
do per hour in a safe way.
Because the [? unit ?]
economics need to make sense.
To have good doctors on
board doing these diagnostics
they need to get they
same dollar per hour
as they will have in a hospital,
in a shift in the hospital,
for example.
So the way to speed up this
things with this prioritization
and double check, and
with decision trees
that they click instead of type.
Like, for example,
a neurologist will
click epilepsy, diffuse,
frontal lobe, diagnose.
So with this, we speed up about
10 times how many diagnostics
they do per hour.
But they know if they misclick
something-- it will happen,
they do thousands per day--
this will go to other doctors.
So it was all a matter
of how you approach them
and how you show the benefit,
and not the technology
itself they actually don't care
if it's running in TensorFlow
in the cloud and on
premise, but they
need to know that is helping
them to make it safe.
So we believe that when you
combine the doctor and the ML
models you can hit 99% accuracy.
ARIE MEIR: Lots of good ideas.
One thing I would like to
share from our perspective,
AI is not going to
replace radiology,
but I think radiologists
that use AI could replace
radiologists that don't use AI.
Because the AI is
yet another tool.
It's like saying I'm not
going to use a computer.
I'm not going to use
digital technology.
I'm not going to
use the internet.
It's just going to make the
quality and the productivity
at lower level.
So we think AI might be another
tool in the arsenal of doctors
that are helping patients.
In this context I
want to-- this topic
came up, like
numbers and economics
and who pays for this.
So I'm actually
curious, so Dan, you
represent the non-profit
sector and you folks
represent the commercial
organizations.
So in your geographies
and your markets,
what kind of economic trends or,
maybe, forces you are seeing?
Like for example
in the US, where
there is a payer and the
provider and oftentimes
they have this interesting
balance between them,
who's going to pay for this
new AI service portfolio?
How does it play
in your markets?
LORENZO RIZZATTO: This is a
very interesting question.
Well, to tell you the truth,
for example, in Italy,
the payer is usually
the government.
So we have a public
health system.
And they have really,
a lot of difficulties
in incorporating
these new technologies
into their payments.
So far, for example,
not even teleradiology
is inside these
lists of services
that the government pays.
So of course, since artificial
intelligence algorithms
lower the risks, and,
at the end, of course,
they make you save money.
In my opinion, for example,
the radiologists themselves
and the organizations and,
for example, the insurances
that cover the organizations
and the radiologists
should pay for these tools
because the risk lowers.
TAKASHI TOCHI: I can't tell
the financial aspect of AI,
but as I mentioned, in
Japan the number of scanners
are very, very many.
We have many scanners but
the number of radiologists
is limited.
So to cover that shortfall we
need not only teleradiology
but we need also AI.
I can't tell to what
extent, but more or less, AI
will be introduced in medicine.
And AI will work together
with radiologists
and then cover that shortfall.
In that context, Japan ranks
top as a country that needs
AI and teleradiology both.
DANIEL MOLLURA: To
answer the question
about who would pay for AI,
first I would put it out there
for all of you to think
about, how exactly will AI
be delivered to these clients,
these medical clients?
Because right now,
if you think about AI
coming about within
PACS, well, then that
means that a PACS vendor
will license or build itself
AI and put it into the product.
Remember, PACS is
a closed system.
No one can just open up PACS
and add new software into it.
It's closed.
So it goes to the client and
then they just use it as is.
So essentially
that hospital would
be paying the PACS vendor
for whatever is in it.
So they would be passing that
cost through to the hospital
through the price of the PACS.
Same goes for hardware.
If you think about
CT, ultrasound, MRI,
or mammography
machinery, that can also
embed AI within the equipment.
So again, it'll be included
as product advancements that
then get sold to the hospitals
in that kind of dynamic.
Then when we think about, well,
who pays for it short term,
middle term, long
term, that's where
the difference between
nonprofit and private sector
and public sector actually
becomes very relevant,
especially in low and
middle-income countries.
As a nonprofit, we have a
much higher risk tolerance
than any of the others do in
private sector and government
because we're mission-driven
and we can afford to lose money.
We can go and do something
for the sake of mission
to put something
in place because we
know the patients need it.
So in the short term, a
nonprofit like Rad-Aid
can have a very high
tolerance for that risk,
whereas private sector will
be very reluctant to take risk
like that initially.
But then once nonprofit can
show that something is workable,
a pilot or something
is sustainable,
that that's where that
risk kind of reduces
and that return on
investment becomes more
palatable to private sector.
And that's why
it's very important
to consider the private and
nonprofit sector partnerships.
Then as you get into
the middle term,
that medium term of nonprofits
and private sectors partnering
in that regard, that's
when government really does
come into play as a
long-term solution.
Because then you're
bringing in the fact
that governments are
never going to get
involved in that initial stuff
that actually has high risk.
That nonprofits can do.
But for long term,
for public sector
and providing public
goods to the population,
that makes more
sense for government.
So short term, for
high risk innovation,
nonprofits are
well-positioned in this space.
And then for short
to middle term,
you've got private
sector partnerships.
And then for the long term
you have a government actor
also coming together.
And that's how a
lot of innovations
have come into
health care, and I
would say that
it's probably going
to be along similar
lines in this case, too.
RAFAEL DE CASTRO
FIGUEROA: I agree
with what Dan said about
how AI will be delivered.
I think this is the main point,
to think who will pay for it.
And this is, in our
case of health care,
linked to regulation again.
So for example, here in the
US you can do teleconsulting.
So there is doctor on
demand, teledoctor.
You talk to your
doctor through a video.
In Brazil you cannot do this,
you need to be B2B, not B2C.
Never a patient can
call us directly.
You need to go to a
local small clinic.
And this clinic will then
access all the specialists
in the hospitals.
If you follow these rules,
you are doing a B2B--
it can be a video call,
but our main goal is exams,
diagnostics on top of
X-rays, MRIs, et cetera--
then it's fully reimbursed.
So it doesn't matter
if it's a local doctor
or is a remote
doctor in Sao Paulo.
The government or the insurers
will reimburse a teleconsulting
or telediagnostics.
So the way that we did,
we embedded our AI costs,
our machine learning costs
per test, per report.
So whenever report change hands,
we receive an amount for this
and the doctor get paid.
And the engineering
cost of GPU, these
are like GPU hours or API calls.
But there is a call,
there is a price per test.
So when you embed
this per report
and then the report
is fully reimbursed,
then the AI cost
is diluted on this,
and that way the government and
the insurers are paying for it.
If I approach the insurers and
say, pay the API call here,
they are not going
to understand it.
But if this is embedded
in the workflow--
so this is why I say it
cannot be an end in itself,
it needs to be a means
to deliver something--
then it's fully reimbursed.
I do have another case where
AI was important for us.
We won a bid with the Sao Paolo
public health care last year,
and so they acquired
the platform.
And there is a price for AI,
but it's not specifically
on the bid, say, we're going
to pay x amount for the AI.
They were asking for features.
For example, we need
probabilistic matching
of patients between
different systems,
because different last names.
So this is one of the
features that they have.
We need to be able to
prioritize emergencies
with machine learning,
was one of the things.
We need to be able to
audit our previous exams.
So they have 20 million
exams for the last 10 years
and now we are running our
models historically on this
and finding cancers that
was diagnosed as normal.
And then we can create
clusters and alerts
and call these patients again.
So it wasn't like a price,
a tag price on this,
but being able to have these
features was a difference that
won the bid, and then the
price is the full platform.
So it depends how we deliver
and legislation, of course.
ARIE MEIR: So I'm
hearing that it's
a complex issue we probably
won't resolve in the next eight
minutes tonight.
One thing I want to
ask each one of you
is what you and your
teams are most excited
about for this year?
Like what are you anticipating.
And what could help
you accelerate?
RAFAEL DE CASTRO FIGUEROA:
We're excited about it.
We have many projects
together, Ariel,
so you already know the answer.
But like this bit
that I mentioned
with Sao Paulo public health
care, it's one of the things.
So what we did in
the private sector
with these 500 hospitals, it
took six years, one by one,
bottom up, and now
we have this network
that is connected
and is running well.
Now we want to take
this to large scale.
So we started to work with
the Sao Paulo government.
And it's a pilot of 35
million citizens, 20 years,
and when it works we'll then
take this to the federal level.
So we're now kind of
developing a playbook of how
to speed this implementation.
So what takes years
now, for example,
we take about 18
months to implement
in a new network in the city.
If it's a clinic, we
can install in only day.
Used to take one
week, two weeks,
and now we start
one clinic per day.
But now to take this
broadly and faster,
we want to learn how to do
a full country in 90 days.
So this is our objective
with Google right now.
We are by expanding fast
to public health care.
And it's different
from the private,
like people are paying for.
It's this governmental project.
We need to be very low cost
to be able to be sustainable
after we deliver the platform.
So all this cost
engineering is getting
way more important
right now, because we
need to deliver a tool
that then is sustainable
without us taking care.
And then disconnecting
these health care centers.
So I think right now we are
just shifting our minds off one
by one hospitals to a more
broader view of population
or health care
management, where we
are applying the same
algorithms that we did one
by one, on top of way larger and
more heterogeneous data sets.
And one thing that's
nice is that when
you compare the metrics that
we have with the top papers
from MIT, Stanford, we've seen
that the algorithm that they
train are trained on top
of the Stanford hospital
with the last GE device.
And when you try to apply
this in emerging markets data
sets with different
devices, different DNAs,
you're not going to generalize.
You're going to lose a lot of
precision and accuracy on this.
And we are thrilled to see
that since we trained this
in different devices in 300
cities from the top [INAUDIBLE]
Sao Paulo through
lower tier devices,
for example, a Chinese
device or a Brazilian device,
and now when you apply these
new data from new hospitals,
you're generalizing very well.
So one of the things is that
you need to take the bias out
of the data sets to be
able to then apply this
to different
populations, and we see
that our experience in the
six years was worth it.
So our goal right now
is to speed up this
to implement in more countries.
DANIEL MOLLURA: I'm very
excited about the partnership
we have for developing an
ecosystem for AI developers
to interface with the
hospitals where Rad-Aid serves.
As I said, by building cloud
architecture and building
capacity in those
hospitals, that
creates an ability for AI
developers to work with Rad-Aid
and to work with those hospitals
to bring AI into existence
for those hospitals.
And this would be an
open-source system.
This would be a
way for developers
to learn more about what
these hospitals need.
This would increase
data diversity
by bringing these hospitals
into those repositories that
really need to be more diverse
for that AI to be accurate.
So this is an important
endeavor we're
taking over the next year.
We invite the AI
development community
to work with us on
this, to really make
this a dream come true as an
ecosystem for AI development
and health care to be together.
TAKASHI TOCHI: Now we
are proceeding a project
with the Google Brain team.
In that project, we are
developing an infrastructure
to exchange images
and AI results.
Hospitals and clinics like ours
will send the images to Google.
And on Google's side, AI scans
and analyzes those images
and then displays the
result. And very soon
we can complete it
and show it to you.
And as Dan mentioned
to PACS vendors,
I think we should change
the present situation,
the situation of
vendor-dependent medicine.
I think we should use AI
like other internet services,
say, a Google search
when you type a keyword
and click a button,
and you get the result.
We can and we should
use AI that way.
And that infrastructure is
not only for this project,
but in the near future it would
be one essential part of an AI
diagnosis system.
Our work at that infrastructure
can support doctors
all over the world.
That's a great honor for us.
LORENZO RIZZATTO: We are
excited as a company for it.
We have some new projects on AI
with the regional governments.
So we are collecting
data from them.
And then we are
developing with them
some artificial
intelligence tools.
And so, of course, it's really
exciting for the company.
ARIE MEIR: So I just want to
add on what Takashi and Dan said
on the ecosystem.
We definitely take an
ecosystem approach.
So our view from
Google Cloud, we
want to enable
application developers
to build AI applications in
health care and radiology
generally, because
these applications tend
to be very narrow.
And it's going to
take hundreds, maybe
thousands of applications.
We believe that it will
take an entire ecosystem
to develop this effectively.
We invest where we can
accelerate this process.
For example, how to develop
better labeling tools
or how to develop
better training tools.
But the application
themselves would
be developed by the ecosystem.
We have a minute
left, and so I want
to ask you in 10
seconds, what's going
to be your prediction
for the next 18 months?
Lightning round.
Who wants to go first?
RAFAEL DE CASTRO FIGUEROA: OK.
Actually, my prediction
is the challenge
that we need to solve.
So I hope we fulfill
this prophecy.
But right now these
models are very narrow.
So it's the same.
Pneumonia, yes or no?
Pneumothorax, yes or no?
What we're trying to break now
is correlating this with a lab
test, for example, with EHR,
and have a deep learning
model to actually
look at multiple signs
to then do a proper
telediagnostic,
because we don't believe
that to only look at an image
is enough even for a doctor.
So imagine the AI
that don't have
any knowledge of the
[? word ?] making predictions
on top of pixels only.
So we're trying to
cross these barriers
and create multi-modality models
that absorb all kinds of health
care signals.
DANIEL MOLLURA: I think
there'll be a full embrace of AI
education in the clinical world
that in the next 18 months,
you're going to see a lot of
other medical professionals
fully embracing AI education
in order to prepare themselves
for the next era where AI
will come into practice.
TAKASHI TOCHI: In this event,
Google Next, in every session,
in every session related to
health care, every speaker,
every panelist says
the same thing,
talking about the problem
of interoperability,
that kind of thing.
To break down barriers.
I think-- and now I'm very
optimistic in the long run.
And I think this change
can be a transition
from paternalistic medicine
to patient-centered medicine.
And that will be
beneficial for patients.
Thank you.
LORENZO RIZZATTO: I see
that standardization also,
in artificial intelligence, will
become more and more important.
So I'm sure Google Cloud will
lead the way in data labeling,
for example, or implementation
of [INAUDIBLE] annotation
in [? the viewers. ?]
This is really important,
and everyone is doing
some private annotation,
or some private data labeling,
but this cannot continue.
[MUSIC PLAYING]